では よろしくお願いします
はい これから今日のテーマ始まります
えーと あの 好機というチャンスという言葉で
このテーマになったのは
あるエピソードがございまして
お釈迦様は亡くなって 3ヶ月間かなね
まあほとんど間もない時は
マハーカッシャパ大長老が
大阿羅漢がね まあブッダの教えをまとめて
サンガたちをきちんとまとめておかないと
教えは長持ちしないそうということで
仏教の責任を取ったんです
それはお釈迦様の期待であって
まあいつかこの人の手に委ねることになるそうとお釈迦様はご存知でしたし
で その時はこのブッダの教えは何でしょうかとしっかり定めておく必要があります
それで 長い間ブッダの側近でお世話したのはアーナンダ長老なんですね
お釈迦様の親戚でもありましたし
それで抜群の記憶力で
もう何でも一回で見事に明確に覚えて暗記しておくんです
そういうことだから お釈迦様がお話ししたところはほとんど知っていて
それでお釈迦様の身の回りのお世話をすることに
そのものすごい幸福な仕事なんですけど
その仕事には他のお坊さんたちもみんな自分でやりたかったんですけどね
アーナンダ尊者は全然無関心な心でいたんです
そんなことはどうでもいいやということはね
それで他のお坊さんたちが
我々は申請したんだけど
お釈迦様には却下されましたよ
しかし なんであなたは申請しないのかと言ったら
アーナンダ尊者がね もし私はその仕事に適しているならば
ブッダ自身が決めることでしょうと
なんで私はお願いしますと言う必要ありますかと
ということで それでお釈迦様はみんなの祈願をね
却下して まあ私のお世話はアーナンダ尊者がしてくれるで
アーナンダがしてくれるでしょうとと言ったんですね
言ったら アーナンダ尊者がその機会ですぐ立ち上がって
まあしかし条件がありますよと
仕事は引き受けますけど
条件がいくつかありますと
その条件をお釈迦様はのんでいただけないとダメですと
ただ 条件は何なのかと聞いたら
まあ一つはお釈迦様はどこで誰に説法をなさっても
それは私に報告しなきゃ困りますと
だからお釈迦様に対するすべてのことは自分自身で把握しておきたいんですよ
それから人々がお釈迦さんに会おうとか
なんとかとか話をすると
それは先に私がそういう人々と話して
お釈迦様に会うか会わないかどうか
会わせるかないかを私が決めますよと
ほとんどの場合は それでいろんな信者さんとかね
まあお釈迦様にお布施したいんですけどと
私に頼まれたら 当然もうパイプ役はアーナンダ尊者になりますからね
その場合 もし私がいいですよと
その信者さんに約束をしたら
お釈迦様は断ることできませんよと
お釈迦様は私が受けた接待に行かなくちゃいけないんだと
しかし 釈尊に直接信者さんがお布施しますと言ったところで
あの じゃあアーナンダ尊者を一緒に連れていく
それはダメですと 私は釈尊が受けた接待は受けませんと
しかし 私が受ける接待は釈尊を受けなくちゃいけないんだということで
それぐらいの条件で いかに見事に完璧にお世話するのかということでね
それで問題はこのお釈迦様は涅槃に入られてから
お釈迦様はアーナンダ尊者が預流果の境地に悟っていたんですけど
もう修行する暇がなかったんですよ
ずっと もう朝も晩も昼もまるっきりお釈迦様に付きっきりでお世話するんであって
ほとんど夜もお休みにならなかったんです
ちょこちょこと微妙にお休みになったんですけど
まあいつでもお釈迦様ももういつ立ち上がって出ていくかわからないし
いつお坊さんたちに喋るかわからないし
いつであっても まあ自分がその自分の仕事をするっていうことでも大変な仕事なんです
だから悟ってなかったんです
でもマハーカッサパ尊者っていうのは
ものすごい厳密で厳しい
で アーナンダ尊者の師匠でもあります
微妙なこの改良改革と絶対認めない
もう保守主義といえば
もうもう完璧に保守主義なんです
で だからこのマハーカッサパ長老が
このブッダの教えをまとめるための結集というね
集めて決断するというね
をやりますと決めて まあお坊さんたちを選ぶんですね
選ぶ場合はもうしっかりした大阿羅漢でなければダメと
完全に悟り開いてないと人間の概念が入りますよ
自我意識が完全に立っている
完全たる悟った人なら
もう微妙にでも間違わないんだということで
阿羅漢たちだけ選んだんですね
まあ選んで選んではいったんだけど
まあ一応469人というんですけどね
一人欠けているんですね
それで本人が自分の弟子であるアーナンダ尊者な
アーナンダがないとこれが成り立たないし
結集は ほとんどお経はその人を覚えているんだから
でもあいつはもう参加させるわけにいきません
もう悟ってないしっていう
すごい厳しい態度をとるんですね
それで日にちもないんですよ
もう明日ということになったんです
もう一人足らない その人はどうしても必要な人
その人がないと もう結集は成り立たない
まあ師匠だからね アーナンダ尊者ところに行って
これ言ったんですね あなたの席は一応空いてはあるんだけど
でも 明日悟ってないとね
それは取り消しやと じゃああなたはまだまだ預流果だからね
入りませんと 言って帰ったんです
それでアーナンダさんじゃ
お釈迦様亡くなってね
ものすごいショックを受けちゃって落ち込んではいたし
それでやること何もなくなったんだから
ものすごい活発に仕事していた方だから
いきなり全てなくなるとね
もうやることはなかったし
ではもう初めて もう初めてなんで師匠の話を聞いたのは
今までお互い喧嘩ばっかりしていたんです
で 瞑想はするんですけど
なかなか心は悟りの境地に達しないんですよ
で 朝方一日中苦労していたんです
うまくいきそうもないみたいと
ちょっとものすごい疲れてて
ちょこっと横になりそうと思って横になろうとした瞬間で
足がもうまあベッドにね
腰をかけて横になろうとして
足が地面から上がっている
その瞬間に完全に悟り開いてしまったんです
だから立ってみなかったし
座ってみなかったし 横になってみなかった
どちらにも入らない状態なんですよ
で まあそれであの朝はなんのことなく
じゃあ私も参加しますと
で アナリスさんが参加したんです
それで大変仏教は助かりました
よかったんですけどね
だからこのそれでこの我々はどんな瞬間で頑張ってもうまくいかない時もあって
なんか期待しない ある時パッとうまくいくというね
そういう好機というかね
チャンスというかね その瞬間というかね
オケッションというかね
まあそう言ってのはよくよく世の中であることで
仏教の世界ではまあいくつでもありますよ
そういうエピソードばっかりなんです
ほとんど だから いろんな悟った方々の説明の中で
どんな時 どういうことで悟ったのかとかね
必ず瞑想ばっかりしやがっちゃって
それで悟ったということでもないんですよ
例えば尼さんの中で この第一人者にしていたのはケーマーという尼さんなんですね
あのゴータミーお釈迦様のお母様じゃないんです
それを最初に出家したんですけど
サーリプッタモクレン仙人の代わりにこの第一人者にしたのはケーマーという
まあもう在家の時はものすごいとても美しい方でしたけどね
彼女はいつ悟ったのかというと
なんかこの まあ普通に修行していて
ある日 自分のちっちゃなね
部屋みたいなところで
一人で まあ女性はとにかく自分住むところはね
ドアかけていなくちゃいけないし
男性は木の下でもどこでもよかったんですけどね
それでこの一応明かりをつけて
油でね ちょっとした明かりで
ただ単に座っていたんですね
瞑想していたわけでもないんですよ
それでこの炎を見ていてね
その油が切れちゃってね
あの芯がね いろいろ大きくなったり小さくなったりして
突然もうかなり大きく燃え上がったりして
ぽっと消えてしまったんですね
自分が一体になって それをじっと見ていたんですよ
で 炎が消えた瞬間で完全に悟り開いてしまったんです
そのように このあの中国の禅の物語にあるような感じで
あの これってわからないんですよ
それに調子に乗っちゃって
いつでも悟れるそうで
調子に乗っちゃうとそれはダメなんです
そこであの道元さん書いてる正法眼蔵でも
あのもう彼がへんとかいうのは妄想ばっかり書くんだけど
で かなり夢想家ですからね
というか まあ詩人ですからね
詩人っていうのは夢想家に決まっているしね
まあ立派な詩人ですよ
だからある禅寺があの
庭のね 掃除をしていると
ちっちゃな小石が飛んできて
箒にぶつけたんですね
もうほんのちょっとの出来事なんですよ
で その瞬間で その禅寺が悟ってしまったと
の音で それは道元禅師がごちゃごちゃ解説するんですね
森羅万象は仏性やと どんなものでも仏法を語っているんだぞとかね
もうあれやこれやとか
これは日本人好みかもしれませんだけど
もういい加減なことといえばいい加減なんですね
で だからあの音はブッダ自身の説法そのものであると
ブッダの説法と この小石が箒に当たった音と違うものやと思ったらならんぞとかね
これはまるっきり同じ
そのものやと それで川の音であるとか
鳥の声であろうか それが仏法そのものであるとか
まあかなり文学的には書いちゃいますけど
まあ論理的なところはありますよ
でもそれは面白いことに誰も禅の方々は発見しないんですよ
道元さん 別にいい加減に妄想語ってるわけでもないんですよ
基本的にしっかりしたある論理があるんです
道元禅師の論理っていうのは
すべて一切無常ですから
無常に目覚めることなんです
だから無常ならざるを得ないもの
何もないんだからね 無常が仏法なら何でも仏法やという論理なんですよ
仏法にならざるものは何もないんだよというところですから
決して問題はないんですよ
言ってることは でも我々の読み方ですね
ごちゃごちゃいい加減になっているのは
それで私は学問を辞めることになりましたからね
あんた方読み方違いますよと言って
いえいえ もう 50 年間やっている読み方で解説しなくちゃいけないんだ
ではやめるぞと いくらなんでも道元禅師が馬鹿にするつもりはないしね
彼がただ仏教を語っているって
私はね しっかりとした態度をとっていてね
あんた方の話になって
ブッダが偉いと思ったって
あんた方の話を聞くと
単なる大馬鹿者に見えますよと
ちょっと頭がおかしいんじゃないかなということでやめましたけど
まあそれで別に先生悩みはないんですけど
で それであの調子に乗ってすぐもうもう何でもいい加減で生きてれば悟るぞということじゃないんですよ
だから私は言いたいのは
この中国で悟ったと書いている人にしたっても
その人は昼も夜も止まず
ずっと修行中なんですよ
もう 24時間もうもう仏法に命をかけて頑張ってるんです
で その中でもう朝ごはん食べるは
昼ごはん食べるは 寺の掃除をするは
いろんなこともやっているんだけど
本人はずっと修行中なんです
修行を一旦停止して掃除機やってるわけじゃないんです
修行を一旦中止してご飯を食べてるわけじゃないんです
だから禅のお坊さんたちの特色はそれで
だから面白い文学になってるでしょうに
誰かさんが会って喋っちゃうと
なんか変なことを言う
それ 変なこと言ってるんじゃないんです
偉い人に会って喋ったっても
本人がこの人 何々社会的な格の悪い人だからと会わせなくちゃ
そんな話ないんですよ
いつでも仏法の世界にいるというね
修行の世界にいるということだから
聞いた質問の返事は 俗世間で出す返事とは変わっていくんです
で そういうことで だから私はまあ
僧徒 禅宗の人々は自分たちが大丈夫
仏教と祝っているのは勘違いやととは言ってるんです
大丈夫 仏教だったら仏教じゃないんだから
これ 命は一生仏教にかけてる人はね
大丈夫にはなるはずがないんですと
それはそれ どうでもいいんですけど
だからこのチャンス チャンスとか我々言い張っていても
ある日突然 偶然にということはあり得ないんです
我々はずっとこの待ち構えていないと
つかめないんですよ なんかボールが投げて
もうどこからわからないんだけど
投げてきたと すぐ捕まったという場合は
いや ちゃんと待ち構えていないとつかめないということなんですから
仏教の伝統の中で このずっとそういう現象があるんだから
これはまあ俗世間の中でも
我々はもうどうやってチャンスをね
生かすかどうかねという問題がよくありますので
何か俗世間に合わせられるのかということで
まあとにかく今までずっと講演というのは
この宣伝している文句とかなり変えて
私が自分なりに分析したんですけど
今日はちゃんと宣伝に沿って説明していきますが
最初には裏切れます 最後には
で 成功と勝ち取るためには
絶好の機会 チャンスをものにできるかが大きな
それは宣伝文句そのものなんです
それは俗世間の生活でも
修行の道でも同じではないか
でしょうか ピンチの後にチャンスあり
チャンスの後にピンチありとも言いますが
今の自分の状況を落ち着いて的確に読めなければチャンスというのは
皆様もとっくに読まれているものだからね
ちょっと尻込み躊躇していると
いる隙にタイミングが何でしたっけ？しっかり焦りから早まった早急な行動を取ってしまった経験は誰にでもあるでしょう
なんか無事が起きてみたいです
それに日頃から心を磨き澄まして
大切な好機を見逃さないように
チャンスを生かせるようにするためには
どのように心掛けが必要でしょうか
お釈迦様と聖者賢者たちを模範にして
心の成長 悟りのチャンスをしっかりつかみましょう
というのは まあ一応皆様もうとっくに読まれて読んでいる文章だと思います
それで私の話それから始まります
それで これタイトルにあったのは
このチャンスとピンチという 2つの単語なんですね
正直なところは そんな単語は仏教の世界ではないんです
チャンスとピンチっていうのは
俗世間ではよくわかりきっていることのようですね
俗世間のレベルではやっぱりあるんだということはもう思ってるんですね
仏教では意味は全くわからない表現ですよ
何がチャンスですか 何がピンチですかと
さっぱりわからないんですよ
仏教から見れば 同じじゃないかと
どちらにしろだって  そういうことで
まあ結論最後に出しますけど
仏教だったらすべてチャンスのみなんです
で なんだこれ ピンチあるのかと
これからはもう一応仏教的に説明していきます
努力により期待した結果になったことはチャンスで
結果は期待外れならばピンチでしょうですね
それは俗世間の考え方ですね
そこまでは簡単にわかりますね
だから次に行きます 考えていただきたいのです
それで あの チャンスというのは
あの 自分の希望通りに行ったところで
あ これチャンスということになって
あまり希望通りになかなかいかない場合はピンチだという
そう言っても 人間にとっては希望っていうのは叶ってほしいもんですよ
だったら必ず人間にはチャンスとピンチは存在するんですよ
希望 願望 計画 期待などがある時のみ
チャンスとピンチという状況が現れる
だからそういうことなんですよ
人々はチャンスとピンチのことを話しているんだったら
それだったらえらい希望
願望 期待 欲望 夢とかね
いっぱい心の中にあるということなんです
仏教の立場 仏教は 1ある程度の希望が叶うこと
2 希望 願望などを乗り越える状態という 2つを教えているんです
仏教は完全一切の希望を成就することではなくて
ある程度の希望は叶ってほしいと
2番目はすべての希望
願望を乗り越えなさいという
乗り越える 超越する 関わりないことになるということなんです
それは仏教の世界なんですね
それから まあまず希望というのは何だと勉強してみましょう
そうしないと順番的にいかないんです
それで希望 願望って何なのか
その特色 どれぐらい どの程度で希望
願望 期待などできるのかということは
人間の思考 妄想できる能力に比例しているのです
難しい文章ですけどね
これわかりやすく言いますよ
いわゆるたくさん物事を考えたり
妄想したりする人にとっては
希望 願望っていうのはそれ分たくさんですよ
あんまり余計なことを考えない
妄想しない人にとっては
欲望 希望なんかは少ないということなんです
だから人は心の中で夢いっぱい抱いてるんだったら
かなり妄想の達人ということなんです
それほど難しいポイントじゃないんです
それから思考と妄想って 2つ言いましたね
それちゃんと覚えた方がいいんですね
思考とは 具体的に 客観的に
データに照らして ある結論に達するための機能として理解しましょうと
思考するということはこういうことなんです
ただ ただなんとなく考えてみたっていうのは妄想であって
何か結論に至るんです
それから いい加減に考えるんじゃなくて
いろいろデータに照らし合わせて
具体的に客観的に考えるんですね
だから この将棋みたいな感じでしっかりした思考パターンなんです
思考っていうのは悪いものではないんです
妄想っていうのは 妄想とは制限なく自由自在に概念が頭の中で回転することなんです
ただゴチャゴチャ考えるは考える考えるは
時々我々は誤解するときもありますよ
時々何か自分が思考しているんだぞと思っても
本当は妄想っていう場合もあります
あの本でこう書いているんだからね
この本でもこう書いているんだからとかね
あんたはどう思いますかね
ああ そうですかね とかね
そういうこともただの妄想なんですよ
何も目的なく 時間の無駄使いだからね
まあ例えば お茶飲みながらご飯食べながら
今の世界の経済状況はどうでしょうかね
あの中国はどうなってるんでしょうかねとかね
そんなのを考えてもどんな結論もないしね
もうたまたまデータ出したってもね
中国の中国は強そうに見えるんですけど
GP なんとかっていうのはね
それほどないんだぞとかね
あんまり当てになるような現実的な話でなかなか妄想ですよ
無駄話ですよ だから時々我々は思考をよく考えている様子で錯覚して妄想するときもあるし
はっきりと妄想するときもあります
あまり結論に至らないんだから
私の定義はしっかりしていますよ
だからこの結論に達する
こちらは結論に達しませんよ
例えば哲学的なことをディスカッションしても
政治経済学をディスカッションしても
社会の道徳はなんせとディスカッションしても
日本の子供の犯罪をやめるために何をしましょうか
誰一人も結論に至らないでしょう
だからすべて妄想なんですよ
テレビですごい時間取って
思い存分妄想するというね
無駄なんです すべて 結論に達しなきゃダメなんです
でなきゃ行動できないんだからね
この間もね 小学生の子供でしょうかね
殺されちゃって ちょっとしたことですぐもう学校から出て
もう殺されちゃって それでみんな随分もうすぐたちまち行動に移すんです
次の日から親が学校に付き添って子供を連れて行くんです
それで 2週間で終わります
毎回でしょ それっていうのは
私も日本に長いんだから
子供が誘拐されたケースやら殺されたケースやらってのはいくらでも出たんですけど
その時みんなお互いに区警の方々集めて
まあ当番で順番で もうそれからもう学校の先生たちも教員たちもあっちこっち待っていて
ちゃんと見張っていてとか
2  3週間で終わりと それど派手にもうちゃんと対策取ってるんだぞとかね
ものすごい無知というか
もう妄想しかできないんですよ
もうはい 次のポイント
妄想には論理性 具体性
現実性は要りません 勝手にやればいいんだから
別に 感情が妄想を引き起こす衝動なんですよ
まあ怒りとか欲とかね
愛とかね もう憎しみとか感情があると
もういくらでも妄想が現れてくるんです
妄想による現れる希望などにも制限リミットはないのです
それから妄想するといろんな希望を期待するでしょ
あの人と一緒になりたいとかね
この人と別れたいとか
いろんな希望っていうのは現れますよ
それ妄想のリミットがないと同時に
希望にもリミットがない
欲望にもリミットがない
もう何でも考えられますから
考えるたびに新しい妄想が現れ
新しい希望が出てくる
だからこのアンリミテッドというね
経済学でも使いますね
アンリミテッドニーズだと
人々のニーズはアンリミテッド無制限であると
しかし資源はリミテッドであると
リミテッドミーンズ そこでリミテッドミーンズからアンリミテッドニーズをどう対応するのかということは経済学であると
うまくやってないんですけどね
だから人間の希望願望っていうのはもう無料ですからね
なぜならば妄想しているんだから
だから経済学者もなんで妄想する連中を応援するための経済学ですかね
いい加減あんた方妄想するなよと
そんな資源ない ないんだと
人間だけ食ってる資源じゃないんだよと言っちゃえばいいのに
それで経済学終わりますでしょう
もっと大事な仕事できるし
その代わりに 役に立たない経済学の代わりに
思考する時も人は感情から離れてないのです
現実性 実効性に欠けた希望をする
それで では 思考する人の希望願望は何やと
思考する人は具体的に考えるんだから
希望計画を立てたら それまた具体的なんですよ
よくデータ調べて結論に至る
ある計画を立てる 問題ないんです
しかし 我々はいくら論理的に考えて立てる計画でも
結構欠陥がありますよ
実行できないこととかね
実行してもうまくいかなかったとかね
無駄になったとかね 代物になったとかね
いろいろあるでしょう
それっていうのは いくらなんでも
いくら思考する人でも感情でしょ
人間には感情がある 欲
怒り 憎しみなど感情は誰にでもある
だから思考するしっかりした人にしても
自分の思考が汚れてるんです
だから計画はいつでも欠陥だらけでうまくいかないということはよく覚えた方がいいんです
計画 希望 願望っていうのは
だから仏教の立場は計画を立ててはならぬってことじゃないんです
客観的に具体的に立てる計画は実現できます
が 人間立てる計画はなかなかそううまくはいかないのはなぜかというと
心が感情で汚れているだからなんです
結果はどのような人でも現実できそうもないぐらいの希望
願望などは大量に合成していることですよ
それでどんな人間でも実現できそうもない大量の希望
願望 合成するんですよ
頭の中で まあ論理的なデータにもってまた合成する
妄想によってまた合成するというね
例えば科学者でもちょこっと宇宙船
今の太陽ももうちょうど飛ばすだけなんですけど
火星で開拓することまで喋ってるんですね
まあそれでもう月に何かもういっぱい人々を住んでもらおうではないかとかね
どうすれば火星の中に入っている氷をね
取り出してもう水を作るのか
妄想ばっかりなんですけど
ろくに 2  3ヶ月とか宇宙にいることさえもいまだにできないのに
いる場合はずっとこちらから食べ物やら酸素やらもう持っていかないと
もし宇宙ステーションができて
宇宙ステーションで全て自立できたならば
もう火星のことを考えたってもいいんだけど
だからもうみんな馬鹿もんで妄想ばっかりしやがってるんですよ
実現できる希望などは 1兆分の1ぐらいのものなので
すべての生命は常にピンチなのです
よく見るといっぱい希望あるでしょうに
うまくいかないでしょうに
1兆分の1ぐらいはなんとなくいきますよ
ということは ピンチでしょ
一生は 仏教以外の人々はもうピンチ
もう真っ最中 妄想のみをする人は希望に押されて自己破壊になってしまうのです
それでもし人が妄想ばっかりしてね
自分の世界だけに閉じ込められると
もう妄想で抑えられて何の希望もできなくなっちゃって
もう引っ込みになっちゃって
自己破壊になるんです
妄想ってすごい危ないんですよ
だから 俗世間では希望すると無制限に希望する
あまりにも妄想しちゃうと
希望を 1個さえも立てられなくなって
自分が潰されているんですね
妄想のせいで だから俗世間にその極端見えるでしょ？何の希望もない
学校は行きたくない 仕事をやりたくない
外へ出たくない 人と喋りたくない
では あんた何やりたいの？何もやりたくないという
もう極端に精神的に 病気に陥っている人々いるでしょうに
喋ってみてください もう喋っても話を聞く余裕さえないんです
頭の中でずっとワンパターンのいくつかの妄想でずっと強烈に回転しているんです
だからどうしようもない
普通のカウンセラーたちにはね
もう話に乗るんだからね
全然もう助けてあげることもできない
たまに私は相手のことを心配したならば
もういきなりショックさせるんですよ
思考に もういきなりすごいショックを与えちゃう
それで驚いちゃって いきなりあの妄想パターンがもうどうしようもなく爆弾落ちゃったんだからね
止まるんですよ それからもうゆっくり成長
整頓してあげたりはする
そういうわけで 我々には新たな悩みも現れてきます
これ大体私はよく使うんですけど
新たな悩みって なぜならば
普通 仕事をすることも大変でしょうしね
あの 料理することも もう掃除洗濯することも楽じゃないでしょうに
もう年取るでしょうに
でもういろいろね もう体がもうどうせもうご飯食べるといろいろ脂肪が溜まるわ
いろんな悪い物質は溜まるわ
体が悪くなっちゃうわ
まあそういうことで 普段生きることさえも大変なんですよ
平和で生きてるんだぞって言ったってもね
家族がいるんだから 家族の面倒を見るということはね
結構大変でしょうし だから普段自然にある苦しみの上に
我々はさらに苦しみを作るんですからね
希望が外れることは決して面白くないのです
悩むことに落ち込むことになるのです
当たり前ですね 希望が外れるのは面白くないでしょうね
それで 1兆分の1しか希望が叶わないと
すごい面白くないと思いますけど
無数の無制限の希望を持っている問題は
希望が叶うよりは失う方がはるかに多いでしょう
悩むことは失望になること
落ち込むこと 悔しくなることなどは運命的になっています
こういう視点で考えてみると
だから無数の希望を持って楽しいんじゃなくて
ものすごく新たな悩みが生まれてきて
運命的になっています
人間の苦しみは 仏教では
例えば人が病気になったとかね
もう徹夜して看病しなきゃいけなかったとか
それも苦しいんだけど
そんなあまりもう生きる苦しみはそんなのはとかね
子供は夜寝ないで泣いていたとかね
お母さんはなかなか寝られること
寝ることできなかったとかね
そんなことでは別にあまり気にしない
でも人間はそうじゃなくて
こうやって余計な存在する必要もない苦しみを作るんです
赤ちゃんが夜中夜泣きするということは
もうどうにもならない苦しみなんですよ
存在する必要もないとは言えませんよ
それはまあしょうがないということで面倒見ればいいんです
自分がすごく疲れているんだったら
誰かにちょっと赤ちゃんもう 1時間ぐらい見てもらえませんか？と頼めばいいんですよ
それぐらいは 我々は存在する必要でもない
ものすごい苦しみを作って悩んでいるんです
だから私はだいたい新たな悩みという言葉で
それを特色つけています
というわけで 仏教っていうのはいつでも結論を出しますのでね
ただ喋っただけでは終わりません
大体日本では嫌がられる
そういうわけなんですよ
みんなまあ喋って ああそうか
なるほど それで終わりたいでしょうね
ブッダはそうじゃないんです
もう早く話を縮めて これは答えです
やりなさいと やるかやらないか
あんたの勝手ですと で
仏教の態度はそういうことなんです
だから答え 希望のダイエットしなくちゃいけないんですよ
本当は希望のダイエットは一番大事であって
肉体のダイエットじゃないんです
お腹が空いてあっても
牛一頭は食べられませんでしょ？私はお腹が空いたんだから
牛一頭もう焼き丸焼きにして食っちゃうぞと思ったっても食べられないでしょうに
だから希望があってもダイエットしないと
闇雲に希望願望を合成するのではなく
実現できる範囲で切り捨てなくてはならないんですよ
ご飯と同じですよ お腹が空いてるんだからといって
もうもう 1 日中何も食べてないんだからといって
3 食は食べられませんよ
一回で ある修行者が私が昔いたところに来て
自分がブッダの道を歩んでいると
勝手な道を歩んでいて
ブッダの道と言っていてね
で ブッダはまあ 1 日 1 食しか取っていないんだと
私もそういうふうにと
ブッダは托鉢したんだから
私もずっともう立っていて
托鉢していて 結構お金儲けているんですけどね
で まあそれはそれでも関係ないんだけど
私は困ったのは この人はもう 1 日 1 食といって
まあまあ もう日本では便利ですから
やりやすい時代ですから
夜食べるんですね 私の家に来た時は
この 話を聞いてたんだから
まあ私はご飯食べてなかったら作ってあげますよと
まあ言ったんですよ 朝から食べてないんだったらね
これ来たのはまあまあ
7時 6時半ぐらいでね
大丈夫ですよと 作りますよ
すぐと言ったら いえ ご飯食べてきたんだと
実はこのカレー３杯食べてきたんだ
これで苦しんでるんです
本人 これで私より随分優れてる修行者やとね
言い張ってるけど こいつは何やと
これと思ったんですよ
なんとかもうブッダは侮辱するんじゃないんだぞと
結局は普段普通の人間は 1 日 3食でしょうね
この人は朝から食べないでいて
夜 3食いっぺんに食べるという
バカでしょうね すごく苦しくて
だから仏道歩んじゃうと
ものすごい健康的でスマートで
頭もしっかりして すごい幸せ
一色でいられるはずなんですけど
あんな調子だったらこの人早死になるでしょうね
だから一日中食べなかったと言っても
食べる時はやっぱりお腹いっぱい
一食分しか食べられませんよ
それぐらいのリソース
人間に必要な生きる上で
このたとえでよくわかるでしょうね
だからたとえ話は大事なんです
頭にきちんと刻んでおいてください
牛一頭は食えませんよと
だから希望がいっぱいあるんだったら
全部切り捨ててほしい
どれぐらい実現できるのかという
その範囲で それだけのことなんです
夢はいっぱいある人と比べると暗いですか？と
では まあ実現できることしかこの人は考えてないんだと
私はそうじゃなくて いっぱい夢を持ってるぞと
なんか明るそうに感じるでしょ？違うんです
誰が暗いんですかと ではない
誰よりも明るい成功者です
ちゃんと希望をダイエットしている人ならば
本人は何やっても成功しているでしょうね
できることしか希望してないんだから
だから楽しいでしょうね
俺が失敗したことはないんだと言えるでしょうね
だから夢いっぱいある人はものすごい暗いんですよ
すごい暗い だから希望をダイエットした人がすごく元気で明るくて
まあ地味でいられませんよ
その人は色々実現しなくちゃいけないんだからね
活発で生きているんです
で その場合は一応体で考えればいいんですよ
まあ一応例を説明したんだからね
口は一つでしょ 人間には
これで胃袋の一つでしょうに
で 我々に言っているのは
人間になんで耳が 2つあって
口が一つでしょうかと
たくさん聞いて ほんのちょっとちっちゃくで喋りなさいよと
それで見てみると みんな喋るだけで全然話は聞かないというね
法則違反なんですね 胃袋なんで一つですかね
ちょっとだけ食べなさいよということでしょう
たくさん食べて欲しければ胃袋２つぐらいあるよ ２
つ３つぐらい 例えば牛なんかはたくさん食べなくちゃいけないし
その代わりにいくつかの胃袋の中で部屋ができてるんです
だから体で考えた方がいいんじゃないんですかね
この肉体で生きてなくちゃいけないでしょうに
なんで無意味なくだらない欲望希望を作って体を燃やすんですかね
火傷するんです そのまま自家発火して燃えるんだからね
だから体で考えれば それから寿命っていうのは短いでしょうに
ほんのちょっと もうせいぜい ７０
８０とかね まあそれもわからないしね
二十歳で死ぬ人もいるし
１０歳で死ぬ人もいるし
だから自分がいつ死ぬかわからないでしょうに
それにもう３０００年経ってももう叶うそうもない欲望ばっかり作ったりして
いかに無意味な生き方ですかと
明日生きてるかないかわからないんだから
今日実現できる希望を期待やればどうでしょうかね
何が悪いんですかね それに具体的に合わせて無意味な希望などは切り捨てるのです
そういうふうに自分の命を考えて
自分の肉体で体で考えて
体には関係ない希望は全部切り捨てるんです
例えば もうヒマラヤの頂上が面白いでしょうねとか
世界の頂点に立ったところ
でも自分の体を見たら
そんなのはどうでもいいということに切っちゃえばいいでしょうね
写真で我慢すると 私みたいに
私も本当は興味あるんですよ
ヒマラヤ山脈には だからいろんなもうそうできる人々は登ったり
いろいろあるでしょう
そういうのはじっと見て
あ よかったとか それで終わり
自分の希望は叶ってるんです
自分が登りたい心は全然ない
でもどんなとこかなとかね
最近も何かこのあの記念日として
このあの最初にヒマラヤ登った人々のね
まあなんか番組があって
面白かったんですよ なんて命かけてそういうことをやってるのかとかね
で それでもう自分の肉体で考えると
もうできそうでもないし
時間もないし だからそこはまでではなくて
ただちょこっとした希望は実現できる希望は
ヒマラヤの頂上はどんな調子でしょうかと
登るということはどういうことでしょうかと
それはビデオで見れば大丈夫でしょうに
だから自分の肉体で考えて希望を作っちゃえばいいんです
他はいい加減切り捨てなくちゃダメなんですよ
それでは我々の たとえ
まあ他人と自分ですね
破壊的な 攻撃的な 残酷な生き方がなくなるんですよ
今 私たちの生き方で我々は何していますか？他人をね
そこの破壊して破壊して生きてるでしょ
なぜかというと 希望を実現できない希望ありすぎ
億万長者なのに また他の人の金まで奪っちゃう
もう戦争までかける かけて人の財産を奪ったりする
それで破壊行為でしょうに
普段生きている時でもものすごい競争的でも残酷でしょ
仕事をやってる時でも
商売をやってる時でも
なんでそれで自分も自己破壊するでしょ
競争しながら 人の足を引っ張りながら
人に迷惑をかけながら
人を倒産に陥れながら
自分が金儲かっちゃうとかね
残酷な生き方でしょうに
例えば最近何かあのマンションの問題が起きたでしょうに
で 残酷ですよ で マンション買った人々はもうマンションから追い出されて
会社はもう倒産は倒産だと平気で言っちゃって
それでローン組んだ人々はずっと買った品物もない代わりにローンだけ払わなくちゃいけない
いかに残酷でしょうかと
だから私は銀行にローン払いませんよという言えないでしょうね
その論理成り立ちませんよ
例えば 私は店に行って何か品物を買う
買って家に電車に乗ろうとしたところで
それを落ちちゃって 線路に落ちちゃって潰れたとする
また店に走っていって
あのね あれ 品物が潰れたんだから
新しいものをちょうだいと言えないでしょうに
だから銀行はあんた家建てるでしょ？家買うでしょ
はい これ 3,500万円やともうお金はくれる
で 月々これぐらい払いなさいと
あの家が基準が間違っちゃって
立ち退きになりましたから
もうお金これから払えませんという話にはなりませんね
残酷でしょう まあ法律はどちらかというと
大体こういう間違いを起こした人を守るようにとなってるんですね
だから裁かれても業者の方がなんとかうまく逃げます
そこまでするんでしょうか
人間に ちょっとした儲けのために
だから そういう建築関係の人々はもう残酷も残酷で
人殺し どちらが残酷かとわかりますかね
たくさんの人々でしょうね
ものせっかく考えて考えて
もう一生一回の出来事だから
日本人にとっては 家一つ作るっていうことは
それ目的にして生きてるでしょうに
一旦家が作ったところで
子供たちも大人になって出て行っちゃっても
何の意味もないんですけど
まあ作った家なんですけど
住む人はいないとかね
まあそれでも人間もそれぐらいの希望っていうのはあって
頑張ってはいる まあそれほど具体性に触れてないんだから
まあ借金でローンででも家ぐらいは建てられる
1軒ぐらいは買えられるということもみんなにはできませんだけど
結構できます でもそこでどう生きてるかというと
まんまる全部盗まれるという
なんでそういう残酷な生き方をしているんですかね
だからもう借りたい もう借りたい
ただそれだけ 法律の弱いところとかね
ちょこっと裏でちょこっとお金あげると
検査審査ははい ハンコ押してくれる
まあ大丈夫や 問題ない
日本人ならみんな正直やとかね
すごく怒るの 私に抗議すると
日本では日本は世界で一番平和で安全で正直な人間がいるんだ
そうするとすごく腹が立ってくるんです
なぜ腹が立ってくるのかというと
これはもう外人という感じで物事を見ないんだからね
この連中はこの国の人々をね
どれほどひどい目に遭わせて
残酷な目に遭わせて苦しませているのかと
それはへっちゃらで 気にしないで
どこかで国で喧嘩していることを見て
あ 日本は安全だとか どこかで国でカバンをこちらに置いておいて
銀行で話している途中でカバン盗まれるでしょう
それを見て あ 日本はそんなことない
なんて幸せな国だと 冗談じゃないんですよ
あれって別にどうったことの盗みじゃないでしょうね
お金がないんだから持っていっただけで
見つかったら法律的にしっかりするでしょうし
こちらの盗みはどうでどうでしょうかね
人間の一生盗むでしょうに
財布とパスポートを盗まれたってもね
人の一生盗むんですよ
だから私が言いたいのは
人間は誰でも同じだと
いい加減でインチキで嘘つきで欲望で残酷ですよ
特定の民族はいません
この地球上で そういうこの言うと自己改革できなくなるんですよ
だから常に自己改革ということを考えて物事を見なくちゃいけないんです
私が怒るのはそういうわけなんです
そんなことを言って いい加減でぼけっとしているとね
この目に見える不幸っていうのはなくならないんだと
勤勉で掃除機でしょうかね
あの建物作った人々は
学校に行って帰ったところで
子供を殺して段ボール箱に入れて平和
この間の木曜日に来てすごく怒ったんですけど
心の中で見せなかったんですけど
もうタイと言っていたんだと
だからタイと比べると日本っていうのはすごい平和な国だと
サクッとその事件をいくつか頭の中でよぎったんですよ
そんな残酷なこと起こるのかとかね
タイでもちょこっとイスラム陣営とはね
まあ南の方でね まあちょこっとやりとりはありますけど
それっていうのはそれなりに理解できるし
まあどうでもいいんですけど
俺たちの生き方っていうのは攻撃的で
残酷で 苦しいものになっているのは
このたくさん希望があるんだからなんですよ
お金ならいくらあってももっと欲しいというとかね
無料の希望 希望があるんだからね
それで結果は自然破壊
命なくなる お互い殺し合う
戦争 仕事をしたっても競争的で
もうものすごい怒り憎しみで仕事をする
だから仕事は面白くない
生き地獄を作ってるんですよ
それの答えは 希望を全部ダイエットすることなんです
体で考えて いらんものは全部カットすることです
それで発展はストップしないのです
よくこんなことを言ったらね
私はこんなことを言っちゃうと
この希望をダイエットしなさいと言うと
みんな言うのは あんた言うどいうのは人間みんな落ち着いて
それだけちょこちょことしたことで満足してると世界は発展しないでしょうと
ということなんです でも違うんです
本当は逆です 人間に達成できることがたくさんあるんですよ
人間勘違いしているんで
頭が妄想だらけでなりそうではないものは希望するんだけど
具体的に物事を考えると
いろんなことありますよ
達成できることが しかし
汚れた希望のせいで世に見えるのは発展もどきです
発展じゃないんですよ
例えばすごい精密な武器開発してるでしょうです
そっちをやってるでしょ
それで発展ですかね 役に立たない機械作ったりとか
今ロボットロボットのペット作ってるでしょうね
あれってみんな威張ってますよ
なんて IT の開発発達でしょうかと
私から見れば人間がダメになったという風にしか映りませんだけど
もう確かに技術はあることはあるんだけど
あの自分の言ってることに反応してくれると
まあ単なる機械がね 面白いことは面白いんですけど
それに喜びを感じて生きていると
もうつまらない 寂しいもいいところでしょうに
なんで窓の外でちょこっと座って
もう自分の部屋の中を狙っているカラスの顔を見て
なんで可愛いですか？と思えないんですかね
私はもうもう大体もう朝方に寝るんだから
朝方になって寝ようかなちょっと思っちゃうと
体が疲れていてだるいし
それでも起きたいしね
もう 1時間ぐらい経ったら起きられませんね
ある日起きられないんだけど
目を開けて外を見たら
隣の建物の上にでっかいカラスが座ってるんですね
そしたら あ こいつでしょ
毎日 3時に鳴くのは と思ってね
これでこうやって首をあっちこっち見ているんですね
あっちこっち それ見るといきなり楽しくなっちゃって
自分の部屋をじっと見ているんだからね
それで元気になっても起きたんですよ
それでロボットのスイッチ入れてこんにちは
こんにちは それで何が楽しいんですかね
そういうものは私は一回使ってそれから捨てるんです
面白くないんです だからまあ
それっていうのは発展じゃないんですよ
成長とともに後戻りできない破壊も起きているんです
だから確かに科学者の方々は
政治家の方々 経済的な方々は
いろんなことを考えて考えてやってはいるんですよ
発展しているように見えるんだけど
どこかですごい破壊も起きてるんです
思考は感情から清らかになるならば
今人間が達成している希望の量より桁の違い
量の希望が叶うことができるんです
我々の思考が汚染しているんですよ
感情で これがなければ
いろんなものを達成することができます
自然も破壊しないで 無料無制限にある
だから仏教的になると桁違い発展が起こるはずなんです
しかし 自然破壊にはなりません
発展の可能性は今よりはるかに多いということなのです
だって仏教的に言えば実現できることしか希望しないでしょ
実現できた また実現できる
どんどんどんどんハッキリした発展なんですよ
もどきじゃないんです
そういうわけで 今までの希望は置いといて
新しく希望を作ってもらわないと
正しい希望はね 希望のダイエットの場合は
小欲知足の方程式で十分です
希望をダイエットするというぐらいだったら
小欲知足という方程式がありますね
それは十分ですよ でも私はそれだけでは足りませんと
ダイエットだけに 別に限りなく発展していても悪くはないんです
限りなく発展するためには
不貪不瞋不痴を実践するために
それは社会で生かすために何をすれば良いのかと考えて実行することです
まるきり別世界が現れてくるんです
ただ 欲を満たすためではなくて
欲をなくすために何かできることないのかどうか
じゃあこうしましょうとは希望を作る
怒りがない生き方をするために
人々にも怒りのない お互い仲良くして生きるために
なんかないかな 仕事にすることはと考えちゃうと
今まで想像もつかなかった新しい仕事なんかは次から次へ出てきます
そういうことをすると
世界は破壊しないでしょ
だから希望を作る場合は
こういうところで希望を作るんですよ
人に協力した生き方したいなと
これは 10人じゃなくて
20人にできる 協力した方が 100人
全ての生命にとかね いくらでも広げますよ
またあります また 慈しみを実践するために
実行するために 慈しみをなんですね
慈しみを社会で生かすためにどうすれば良いのかと考えて実行する
慈しみはこれ仕事にしなくちゃあかんとと考えて
これを実現するためにどうすればいいかと考えて
いろいろイメージ作って
いろいろ計画を立ててと頑張ってみると
全然やられませんよ 社会からは慈しみの実行だから
周りは協力してくれる
自分の物事が聞くはうまくいけばいくほどみんな幸せでしょうし
そういうことでいくらでも希望を立てられます
その希望は自己破壊的ではなくて
反対に自分を成長するんです
だからそういうことっていうのは
いまだかつて世の中でない
人間の考え方には 面白いことに
宗教の本柄 道徳本いっぱいあるんだけど
本当に生き方そのものはこうであるべきというふうには言わないんです
ただ 罪を犯しているんだから
ちょこちょこっといいこともしますよっていうぐらいの格好なんですよ
仏教はそれではなくて
生き方そのもの そうでなければいけませんと言うんです
希望よりははるかに大きい結果になるんです
それで本人が希望したことよりも
結果は最大になるんです
そこまではうまくいくと思ってはなかったということは言えるんですよ
まあびっくりやと だから何かに挑戦して
自分の計画よりももうびっくりの結果だったら
いかに幸せかとわかりますかね
そういう生き方できるんですよ
この道では希望の 1兆分の1を叶うではなく
希望より何倍も高い成功を収めるんです
全部逆になるんです 今の生き方は 1兆分の1だけで
成功は仏教的になってくると
もう 100%成功したかったんだけど
残念なことに 110 800%成功しちゃったということになるんです
まあ他宗教の例なんですけど
やることないんだから
マザーテレサがね インドにもう捨てられてあって
処分されちゃって まあやることはね
インド人はあまり別に宗教ではね
みんな宗教だから神様信仰してるんだからね
わざわざとヨーロッパ人みたいに特別扱いもしない
宗教はね 非常なことだからね
うまくいかない それでまああちこちホームレスの人やら死にかけてる人をちょこっと助けてあげようというね
まあちょこちょこっと始めたことなんですよ
別にあの大胆な考え方も何もなかったんです
教会に報告するときは
あの 2日で死ぬ人  3日で死ぬ人でも
洗礼を受けて死ぬ瞬間でね
朦朧としているんだからできるしね
あんた神様信じます はい
信じます はいはい それで
それで私は 10人カトリックにしたんですよとか言えるでしょうね
そんな程度で始めたもんなんですよ
しかし 彼女はまあ人を助けましょうと
これは自分の修行でもあって
イエス様に対する自分の尊敬でもあるということで
結果はどうですかね 本人にももう把握できないほど大きくなっちゃったでしょうね
だから普段 1兆分の1の成功じゃないでしょうね
逆でしょうね だから清らかな方で言ったら
他宗教にしたってそういう結果であって
これもっと綺麗な心で見てみた
彼女はあの自分のああいう考え方をちょこっとなくなったならば
もっとすごい結果になると思いましたけどね
それでその話は終わり
新しい希望を作ってほしいということで
希望論は終わります 次のポイントはチャンスは合法的ということで
もし希望は論理的で合理的であるならば
チャンスに出会って実現できたとしましょう
では 自分が論理的な具体的な希望がある
チャンスに恵まれてうまくいった
成功しましたとしましょう
それは合法的な行為です
まだわからないでしょう
うまくいったら合法的なんです
必要な原因と条件が揃ったので
ふさわしい結果が生じたんですよ
条件が揃っていたのでうまくいったんですよ
だから逆らってないんですよ
法則に だから合法的っていう単語を使っています
ここでの法律は因果論なんです
因縁論なんです だから法律はある国の一部の人間が自分の妄想するものですけど
宇宙生命全体の法律は因縁論ですからね
それは誰にも乗り越えることできませんよ
だから因縁に逆らっちゃうと失敗する
因縁に沿って生きてみると成功する
だからチャンスに恵まれたといい加減なことを言うんだけど
単なる合法的な行為なんです
ですから ピンチは違法行為です
外の世界の原因状況は揃っていない時
または自分自身の状態は因縁に合わない時
希望する結果は出ません
こちらに欲望があってもね
で 例えばもうリンゴの花が咲いていて
じゃあ明日リンゴを食わなくちゃと思ったってもね
こっちの欲望があってもね
外の条件は揃ってないでしょうに
あるいは自分が準備していないと
例えばいい仕事はあるんだけど
自分がまだまだ資格取ってない
大学は落第ばっかりしちゃって
もう卒業もしていない
自分 知り合いの人々のところで
もういろいろ親戚関係で立派な仕事はある
しかし 大学ぐらい卒業しないと
いくら知り合いの親戚の会社であろうとも入れることはできないとか
だから自分の準備ができていない
それで失敗するでしょうに
ということは違法行為ですね
条件に合ってないということで
良い結果を期待したことさえも違法です
自分と外に条件が揃ってないのに
希望だけはああなりたい
こうなりたい 金持ちになりたいとかね
条件揃ってない だから希望した時点でも違法行為しています
違法です 強引に無理に希望を叶うように
あれこれと手を打つことも違法行為で悪にもなるんです
だから私は冗談みたいな単語を使いましたけど
きっちりした仏教倫理学なんですよ
だから悪行為って何やというと
そういう行為なんです
とにかく金儲かりたくて資料を誤魔化したりして
あのもう政府が決め 共同で建物を作らないで
それで金 自分で余分に儲かるとかね
明らかに違法行為でしょうし
悪でしょうに その人はもう罪を犯しているんです
妄想で感情で妄想する希望期待は具体性を持たないので
世の因縁法則とは関係ないものです
自分一人勝手に妄想して
あれこれという希望を作っても
それは具体的な世界と関係ないんですよ
例えば ある人が精神的な病気で
みんな私の悪口を言っているんだと
だから攻撃しなきゃダメやと思って人に攻撃しようしたっても
違うでしょうに 状況はみんな興味ないでしょうに
でも精神的な病気の人は自分の悪口を言ってるんだと言って攻撃する
本人にとっては論理にかなった行為なんですけど
客観的に見るとえらい迷惑で
それでその人はもう一生どこかで閉じこもることになるんですよ
精神的な病気やったことで
だからそういうのは罪になるんですよ
例えば精神的な病気で責任問われませんというのは言うでしょ
法律で あの女の子がお母さんに毒を飲ませたケースでもね
随分丁重に扱ってますけど
私はそれがすごく嫌なんですけど
だから日本の社会っていうのは
このもうどうでもいい罪はすごい大げさにするし
とんでもない罪なんかすっごくもう丁重に扱うという
で まあそういうことで
このだからと彼女にはあの自分も精神鑑定しなくちゃいけないんだとか
いまだに認めてないんだから
親に毒を飲ませたっていうことはね
だからって冗談でしょうに
本人がきちんと計画を立てて
動物実験もして 子供を絶対もう疑わない
あの母親という人をね
産んで育てた母親にね
どう見ても もう私はもうそれだけはあまり悪人を憎しむってこと
私全くないんですよ どんな悪人でも改良してるっていうのはすごいできると思ってるんです
あまりやったことはないんですけど
あの人はもし妄想してみましょう
で 何かできますかね？私は断ります
まあ断る まあなんとか言うんだけど
全く言うことは違うんです
だからもう だから本人にとってはすごく論理的なんですけど
宇宙的な生命の法則から見ればとんでもない話ですよ
例えば精神的な弱い人が
誰かが自分のをちぎってみて
また別のところにわざと私のことを無視しているんでしょうとかね
侮辱していると言ってぶん殴ったりしちゃうと
それで明らかにこの人は病気だということになるでしょうね
そこで法律では精神的精神鑑定して
やっぱり責任は持てないんだということで無罪にしましょうって言っても
仏教ではこれはできません
仏教ではなくて 宇宙的な法則ではそれは成り立たない
仏教 仏教で言っても意味がないんでしょうね
本人が何か考えて何か実行した
それだけ だからまあ罪は罪なんです
強引に結果を出そうとしても
社会の世界の秩序が壊れます
逆に我々は自分の希望をなんとか実現してやるぞと頑張るとどうなるんですかね
秩序を壊れるでしょうね
例えば 母親は強引に子供に勉強させてえらい知識人にしてやるぞとか
一流の大学に入れてやるぞと思って
そこを強引になっちゃうと秩序壊れるんですよ
子供は全く勉強嫌いになるとかね
もう暴力振るうとかね
あるいは人を殺して犯罪を起こすとか
何かになっちゃいますよ
だから立派な悪行為です
妄想した願望 希望を何とかして実現しようと思っちゃうと
その時点で罪を犯しているんです
悪行為をしているんです
よくよく見ると 社会はだから困っているんです
だから犯罪があるんです
だから戦争があるんです
人殺しがあるんです すべて妄想を実現しようとしているだからなんです
北朝鮮は原子爆弾を作るのも
自分こそ世界で一番強い国民やと
素晴らしい実現的な思考を持っているんだから
すごい現実的で だってそこは外へどこにも行かないと
自分のいる国が一番大きいんですよ
他のものを見てないと
まあ自分で家で育てたものとかね
あの平壌でしたっけ？あの街は
そこはすごいなと アメリカ人だったら腰が抜けるでしょう
このビルはビルと思っちゃうでしょうね
だからまあそれで原子爆弾まで作って脅してやるぞとかね
まあそういう妄想の世界でね
もうすごいもう問題は起きる
俗世間でいう成功はほとんど無理に行った違法行為の結果です
世間でいう成功者は成功者って言っても
みんな違法行為やってます
それから次のステップ
チャンスに対する注意があるんです
1自分の計画 願望などは具体的で正しいものなのか
必ず実現しなくてはならないものかということ
希望を作る前に これ こんな希望って正しいんでしょうかとか
こんな希望叶わなかったらなんか困ることがあるのかと
あ この希望ならどうしても叶わなくちゃいけないんだよっていうんだったらやらなくちゃいけない
そう 若者がよく言うのは
もう大学は行きたくない
あれもごちゃごちゃ言うんじゃなくて
受験受かろうよと とにかく受験するんだったら合格しろよと
この馬鹿 大学に行くか行かないか
それから考えなさいよと
落第して俺が行かないってかっこ悪いでしょうね
だからどうしてもこれやらなきゃますってこと出てきますよ
2番目の注意は 実現できるような社会環境
状況が現れたのかと で
社会の状況はちょうどいいでしょうかと
私にはこういうこと 私はこういうことをしたいんだけど
どうしてもしなくちゃいけないんだけどと
しかし 状況は揃っているのかと
私の例で言えば 人間なら誰でもブッダの道を歩んだ方が正しいんですよ
すごい幸せになります
しかし 私にはいくらでも不幸な人々っていうのは
もうあまりにも見えるわ
見えるわ 見えるわ なんでそんなことするのか
でも喋れませんよ 状況揃ってないんです
その本人がやっぱり困ってるんだとか
なんとか勉強しなくちゃっていう風に来ると
まあ条件揃っていて では教えますということになるんです
ただ単に人が悩んでるんだからといって
夫婦が喧嘩してるんだからといって
お母さんと子供が喧嘩してるんだからって
そちらに行ってごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ仏教を喋るんじゃないんですよね
そうするとダメでしょ
それはもう違法行為で
そういうことで 社会の状況も計算も考えてみる
実行する自分自身の状態は熟しているのか
これ 3番目と書くのを忘れちゃった
注意３ で これから社会の状況は揃っている
でも自分の状況は揃っているのかと 3
番目に考えなくちゃ からですね
例えば勉強するために東大の状況は全部揃ってますけど
だからで自分がサッと行ってはい
勉強ってありえないでしょうに
東大で勉強したければ
まあ東大では社会ですから
東大はね その社会の準備も整っていますが
本人の準備も整ってないと
だいたいそういう 3つぐらいの注意があります
よく覚えておいてほしいですけどね
1希望そのものが正しいか
どうしても叶わなくちゃいけないものかと
1 2番目はそこを叶うために環境が揃っているのか
3番目 自分の準備ができているのかと
その 3つで成り立つのです
次 また特別なポイントでチャンスはピンチになる
このピンチは状況によって違法になることもある
チャンスかな ピンチというチャンスの方がいいみたいね
で チャンスに変えてください
そこでこのチャンスというのは
本当はチャンスなのに
いわゆる合法的なことなのに
もしかすると違法になる可能性もあります
例えば 環境が揃ってないのに良い結果を出そうとすること
前に出した例なんですよ
子供っていうのはある程度で遊べなくちゃいけない
もう人間として成長するためにいろんなことを学ばなくちゃいけないんだから
この遊ぶも一つなんですよ
遊ぶことも 肉体的な成長と反射とか
いろんなものを学ばなきゃ
それ遊ぶなよなんて言って
強引にピアノを習ったり
いろんなことをやらせたりしちゃうと
もしかすると子供はとんでもない不遇な結果になる可能性はあります
そうなっちゃうと 子供に勉強させることはいいことなんですけど
結果が悪くなったんだから
もう違法行為なんですね
だからチャンスはチャンスであっても
あまりやりすぎになると違法行為になる
良い目的なのに努力もしたのにうまくいかなかった
これは条件が悪かったという話で
このピンチは悪ではありません
逆に言えば 自分が正しい
良い清らかな目的でしっかり頑張ったんだけど
結果はなしと その場合はあまり世の中の条件は揃ってないんです
それは別に悪行為じゃないんです
そんなもんで 世の中は
このピンチは悪ではありません
実行する個人の心の問題もありますよ
目的は良いが 感情が入って心が汚れる
良い目的なんですけど
感情が入り込む 例えば人を助けようと思ったところで
もう例えばおじいさん
おばあさんたちの面倒を見ようかなと思った時
おじいさん おばあさんたちっていうのは
体不自由な割にすごい頑固でしょ
ちょっとしたことに怒ったりもする
このヘルパーさんたちにおじいさん
おばあさんから見れば
ヘルパーしたってもう孫ぐらいのもんだからね
あまり気にしないんですね
これ何やってるの？とか怒ったりするんですよ
そうすると自分が一生懸命やってるのになんだこのじじいばばあはと思ったりして殺したりするでしょうに
日本は平和な社会だからそんなことやらないとかやってますけどね
そういうことで チャンスはピンチになる可能性もありますよ
感情が入っちゃうと 途中で感情が入ったりするとかね
先生が一生懸命真面目に勉強している途中で
もう感情が入っちゃって
もういても立っても我慢できなくて
とにかく勉強しろ させてやるぞということになると
ちょっと悪い結果になったりもする
それから自分に自信がなくて怠けになる
あるいはもうやってもいいんだけど
うまくいくかいかないかわからないんだから
自信がないなと思っちゃうと怠けになるんですよ
さっさとやらなくちゃいけないし
だからで感情入ってはいけないし
行動より結果ばかり気にする
何かやるときは結果ばっかり気にする無知な人もいますよ
そうすると何もできなくなっちゃう
チャンスなのに生かせなくなっちゃうんです
やってもいい結果出るかな
この場合は とかね まあちょこっとの結果出したら
やらん方がいいんじゃないかとか
余計なことを考えたりする
そうするとチャンスはピンチになって悪行為になります
世の中の波に耐える精神的な強さに欠けている
時々何をやっても世の中に波があるんだからね
何でも滑り台みたいな感じでうまく滑るわけないんですよ
生きるっていうことは
滑り台は逆に滑ることですからね
結果難しいんです 逆に滑れますよ
子供たちやってますからね
一番下に座って 足でもう手でもう頑張って頑張って頑張って上に滑るんです
で 私にとってはそれはすごい面白く
可愛く見えるんですよ
上からサーッと下に滑るんじゃなくて
下から上に滑ってやる姿
そういうのはすごい明るい元気な子供たちなんですよ
でも結構大変ですよ  1 センチも滑れませんから
上に だから 1 センチごとに自分で努力しなくちゃいけないんです
人生っていうのはそういうものなんです
でも それに耐えれない人っていうのはうまくいかないんですよ
ということは チャンスなのに
本人のやり方次第でピンチになってしまう
チャンスは合法的な行為だから善行為なんです
幸福になります ピンチは違法行為だから罪なんですね
さらに 個人が自分自身で心の中に育てるべきものがあるのです
そこでチャンスを生かすために
個人個人が自分一人の力で育てなくちゃいけない
この精神的な あるエネルギーがあるんですよ
これは人に何することもできません
一人一人がやらなくちゃいけないんです
それはどうしても必要なんです
これはパーリ語ではもうアーランバダート
ニッカマダート パラッカマダートというんで
ダートっていうのはこのもうもう種というか芯というかね
もうどうしても骨組みで必要なものということなんです
骨みたいなもんなんです
ダートっていうのは で
これ意味はね スタートする勇気
進む勇気 耐える勇気ですね
何でも始めましょうということは大変なことですよ
そこでやろうではないかというね
なんのことなく 気楽にはい
じゃあやりましょうというね
その精神状態は一人一人自分で育てなくちゃいけないんです
誰かに尻を叩いてもらうまで待っててもあまりダメです
今は少々少将時に似たものですよ
これがないと成功はありません
いくらチャンスに恵まれても
だって日本って教育的に見ると世界一流の教育レベルある国でしょうね
しかし 頭の悪い人ばっかりでしょうね
チャンス生かしてないんですよ
まあそれはちょっといい加減な言葉なんですけど
真面目にとってはいけませんだけど
あの ただ アメリカとかね
ヨーロッパと比べると
向こうはもうむちゃくちゃノーベル賞を取っちゃうわ
同じレベルの科学者がいるんだけど
なかなか日本の場合はね
ということもないわけでもないし
まあそれからね 学校にも行かないわと
勉強はしてないわとかね
いくらでもいるでしょうに
だから条件あっても成功するわけじゃないんですよ
世界一流の大学 大学 高校とかあるんだからといって
だったら自動的に日本の子供たちみんな頭のいい人間になるということはあり得ません
本人一人一人でこのスタートする勇気やら進む勇気やらとこはないと
自分の家の隣にスポーツセンターがあるんだからといって
自分がもうね 健康で体力ピンピンでいられるわけないでしょうに
大丈夫 家の隣はもうスポーツセンターだからと
だからそれよく理解してください
条件揃っただけでいいわけじゃないんです
チャンスとピンチの区別
これからもうほとんど話終わります
セクションひとつだけで
で 一応まとめ それで具体的な希望と妄想
観念的な希望という 2つありますね
前者はチャンスで 後者はピンチですね
実行できそうもない希望を切り捨てること
人生はほとんどチャンスになる
そうなると 因縁法則 自然の流れということを無視するから
ピンチは意欲です これはできない
誰にも 環境に恵まれても
心の準備 構えが必死中です
環境に恵まれたんだからといってうまくいくわけじゃないんです
それでまとめ 希望の選択
私は一応この感じでも考えてくださいと
選択はこれなんですけど
これ選ぶことね それも大事です
汚れた感情から発生する希望をやめて
清らかな善なる感情によって希望を立てる
もう説明しました 貪瞋痴ではなくて
布団不尽知のことをやってくださいと
慈しみのために頑張ってくださいとは言っておいたんだからね
それなぞ選択といってもそういうわけなんです
だから希望を立てるんですよ
希望はダメっていうわけでもないんです
人間に想像もつかないほどの成功を収めることができる
人生はチャンスだけに溢れることになる
もう全部まとめですよ
あまり気にする必要ないんです
全部説明しました ブッダの教えに従うならば
上限のない成功と成長が期待できる
皆様というか 俗世間にあるのは無数の希望なんですけど
達成はできません 僕は区別希望を捨てろと言いながら
人間には上限のない成長を約束する
そんなところかな それで一部は終わります
で ちょこっと休憩いたします